в рамках проекта лидера цепровых и трансформации 2026 сегодня мы будем
разбирать задачу номер 8 направления город от компании-постановщика,
департамент же лично коммунального хозяйства. Задача - это сервис
прогнозирования аварии и управления, ремонтными работами инженерных коллекторов,
да, Москвы. Вместе с нами на встрече ментер задача Станислав.
Станислав обязательно с вами познакомится сейчас и представители компании, это
вдовинка Гепьени, Крылосов, Антон. Ментер будет вести содержательную часть и
последовательно разбирать вопросы вместе с постановщиком. Обращаю внимание, что
встреча записывается и если что, если вы рукой опоздали, вы можете все просмотреть в записи.
Итак, перед началом напомню порядок нашей работы. То сессия продлится полтора часа.
Сначала мы разберем вопросы, которые мы заранее собирали форму. Дополнительные
вопросы можно будет задать после того, как мы пройдем собранный список. Я отдельно сообщу
о такой возможности. Также все вопросы, которые вы писали в чат, передавали
экспертом и ментеру. Задать вопросы можно будет двумя способами. Первое - это написать
в чат встречи или задать голосом. Второй вариант. Для голосового вопроса надо будет,
чтобы вы подняли руки в телемосте, дождались пока я предоставлю вам слово и после этого
вы включаете микрофон, коротко представляете, задаете один вопрос по задаче, а зачем тем вы
включаете микрофонную и опускаете руку, чтобы не было лишнего шума. Микрофоны участников и
камеры выключены во время созвона, пока слово не предоставляется персонального. Демонстрация
участника происходит только после голосования со мной и ментером. И уточнение по текущей теме мы
рассмотрим сразу остальные вопросы в конце, если у нас останется время. Сообщения в чате или
поднятой руках, честно скажу, не гарантируют, что мы успеем рассмотреть ваш вопрос, но искренне
постараемся. И несколько таких небольших организационных моментов, пожалуйста,
проверьте, что ваша команда состоит в чате по задаче. Достаточно одного человека,
который будет передавать всю информацию команде, но лучше вступить всем составом,
потому что в чате мы публикуем важную информацию по проекту, какие-то уточнения, какие-то
организационные объявления. В качестве решения необходимо будет прикрепить ссылку на вашей
охранительще, на платформе внутри выбранной задачи, ссылку можно прикрепить заранее,
чтобы не зависеть от работоспособности платформы, деплайнов и так далее. Убедитесь,
что она открыта для просмотра, и эксперты могут ознакомиться с вашим решением. Все вопросы по
задачи и организационной вопросах, задавайте в чат, можете тегать меня, Ирина Нижняя,
по чертове, ЛЦТ. Ничего страшного, если другие команды увидят, то что чаще всего вопросы одни и
те же. Личные сообщения, прошу писать вас только сугубо по каким-то индивидуальным вопросам,
которые касаются только вашей команды, и если вдруг вопрос окажется общим, мы
опубликуем ответ в общей ветке. На этой встрече мы рассматриваем исключительно вопросы по теме
задачи, поэтому просьба соблюдать деловой формат без обсуждения каких-то политических религиозных
и других посторонних тем, без оскорблений, спама, рекламы, ссылок и так далее. То есть такие сообщения
мы не рассматриваем, а при повторном нарушении модератор будет отключать вам микрофон или
удалять вас полноценно со встречи. На этом вступительная часть завершена. Я передаю слово
Станиславу для вступительного слова по задачу. Да, коллеги, добрый день еще раз. Мы сегодня будем
разбирать задачу в САТСССР, спрогнозирование инцидентов в Украине, ремонтами, работами,
инженеров и коллекторов в Москвы. У нас присутствуют коллеги, эксперты со стороны и департаментой
даже как раз и мозга некоторая и так далее. Вот, мы получили ваши вопросы. Сейчас я запущу демонстрацию, работа у вас там.
Какие будете, пожалуйста, что вы не видны? Да, отлично. Значит, получили вопросы, их довольно много.
Там более 130, по-моему, если не ошибаюсь, не считал. Соответственно, я их систематизировал обообщил,
то есть здесь обообщенный вопрос исходя из количественных показаний популярности некоторые. Да,
то есть видно, что допустим это вопрос задавали 10 командам, 9, 8 и так далее. Вот, мы пойдем по ним.
Я сделал список из 20 вопросов. Вот, постараемся успеть все. На предыдущий сессий под другим
задачем мы успели уважиться. Да, но это прям рекордная история. Ничего страшного, если мы пройдем не
все. В целом, в популярности идут, я думаю, вы все равно слушаете ответ на свой вопрос. Вот,
в дальнейшем, если вдруг мы не смогли на какой-то вопрос ответить здесь и сейчас,
такой программ может быть, мы постараемся не гарантируем, мы постараемся здесь и позже и потом
этот список вопросов и ответов вам набрать. Итак, начинаем по степени популярности. Первый у
нас был вопрос, это цельевая перемена, что считать отказом и инцидентом. Вопрос звучит примерно,
да, вообще на таким образом, как формально определяет отказ датчика, где находится цельевая
мета. Дельный код событий неисправен или запись журнала "УДС" или что-то еще. И что физическое означает
неисправен? Подтвержденная поломка, устройство или шире. Ну и тогда, в общем, если есть у нас ответ,
колени со стороны москалектора могли бы прокомментировать, если это возможно.
Коллеги, да, мы заполнили вот опросник, где вот вопросов симпатизация, вторую вкладку,
там как раз вот эти все, да, они там как раз есть. Этот файл, он вообще доступен коллегам?
Да, вот здесь как раз дублирующие вопросы, они в принципе плюс-минус друг на друга похожи,
да, есть кто-то, да, да, да, вот они как раз есть. Вот, просто мы можем идти по этому списку,
можем идти по первой к платке. Лучше как-нибудь, потому что я его общил, чтобы они были более общими,
да. Давайте тогда голосом проговорим. Значит, отказ датчика. У нас существует самым главным объектом
предприятия, коллектор, как сооружение. То есть это не трубопроводы, не кабели связи, которые можно
в онлайне мониторить в виде деградации, допустим, сигналов, что-то еще. Здесь подразумевается,
что происходит по сути бинарная логика, то есть либо да, либо нет, либо тревога, либо не тревога.
Сами датчики, естественно, могут быть как повреждены сознательно, это уже какая-то там,
ну, физическое нарушение. Так, и с поцепочки, скажем так, начиная от отказа какого-нибудь контроллера, модема,
оператора связи, например, то есть это может быть и по технологиям 2М мобильная связь, это может быть
физический кабель, который протянут, оптика, медь, это неважно. То есть здесь идет речь именно про то,
что фактически датчик, который вышел из строя, может за собой тянуть целую вот эту цепочку. Здесь вопрос
агрегации, то есть до какого уровня агрегации мы должны дойти в дереве объектов, то есть в обратную
сторону, то есть от датчика. Дальше идет шина данных, дальше идет соответственно питание,
дальше идет контроллеры какие-то, дальше, да, телекоммуникационная инфраструктура, дальше там сверх
какие-то уже разумы в виде каких-то суперсервисов, которые агрегируют, может быть они сломаны, может
быть они там, весь сервер там вышел из строя, то есть такой тоже может быть. И вот здесь нужно просто
понять, какую все-таки уровень вот этой абстракции мы рассматриваем. В журналах, которую мы бы грузили,
получается там, только конкретный датчик один сам по себе, не связанный вот в эту цепочку в дереве
объектов, к сожалению, это связано как и с технологической особенностью, то есть может быть информационно
питающая линия, в ней допустим 48 вольт, она питает сразу там десятки объектов учета, ну то есть
по сути каналы данных, они будут на всей этой питающей линии, то есть любой датчик, например,
если поведиться по, скажем так, вандалом специальным образом, то он за собой потянет сразу вообще
всю линию передачи вместе с питанием этих датчиков. То есть это уже зависит больше, наверное, от
производителя, то есть такой расширенный ответ именно зависящий именно от структуры паспорта системы,
вот это инженерный систем. Если же мы берем, допустим, цифровые датчики, которые действительно
можно адресно идентифицировать, уникально их опрашивать, еще и получать от них какой-то цифровой
сигнал, согласно, допустим, какому-то интервалу значений, то есть, например, температурный датчик,
он дает именно температуру. Газовый датчик, например, он меряет газовоздушную среду, то есть,
например, там отдельный датчик на метан, отдельный датчик на атом, СО, отдельный датчик,
например, на кислород. Вот здесь, да, здесь можно уже действительно прогнозировать более точно,
более ярко, так сказать, высвечивать любую тенденцию. Что еще можно? Можно, соответственно,
проводить корреляции на основе того, что датчики могут быть создавать так называемые логические
домены. Как это выглядит на практике? Ну, представьте свою квартиру, например, да, офис,
и у вас два датчика стоят рядом, избыточна рядом, и мы их создаем как один логический домен. То есть,
если хотя бы один датчик дает тревогу, но второй не дает тревогу, то мы считаем, что тревожного
сообщения не существует. То есть, это технологическое и диагностическое сообщение, но именно как
тревожные сигналы именно как вот в целом, что стекло, например, не разбито. Вот такой тоже можно
создать как вот логический домен из двух-трех там, например, датчиков сразу в цепке. Поэтому здесь,
коллеги, я бы предложил все-таки, во-первых, разделить вот те датчики, согласно журналу,
которые бинарные, ну, то есть, да нет и без варианта. На цифровые, которые содержат в себе значения,
числавы, и третье, соответственно, те, которые можно собирать вот какие-то цепочки последовательности,
например, рост температуры. То есть, здесь очень легко. То есть, есть линейный объект, у него там
рост температуры где-то там превышен, где-то наоборот понижен, там колод, как говорится, тепло,
жарат, там все что угодно, можно какую-то тенденцию. Так, ну, ответил максимально как бы расширенно,
если есть, как говорится, комментарий, можем ответить. Да, нет, соответственно, нет, более-более чем,
мы пойдем дальше, потом, да, соответственно, у нас будет останется время, мы чуть более подробнее
вернемся к этим вопросам. Я думаю, более чем развернуть ответ. На один из самых популярных вопросов.
Значит, на следующий у нас вопрос по метрикам, оценке, качество и лидербок. У нас сохраняется
незначение Precision 0.7, 0.05 из описания трека или команда должна предложить и обосновать
толщины пороги. И какие, ну, и что из этого приоритетия. Посмотрите, то есть, это указано,
что у нас эти два значения стоят по умолчанию, да, но у администратора есть возможность их
поправить в зависимости от. И эта зависимость, соответственно, она у нас, ну, как бы, она зависит
ровно от того, насколько качественные данные мы получили. Вот, что из этого приоритетия, да,
там, ну, смотрите, то есть, на самом деле, это все равно две разные метрики, да, и что из этого
приоритетия сказать пока сложно, то есть, мы будем сами тоже, наверное, смотреть и играть,
этим министориям, коллегам тоже, соответственно, было смотреть и играть, потому что, грубо говоря,
там одна метрика означает, сколько, там, условно, мы вообще поймаем, да, там, событий,
и сколько мы упустим из настоящих событий. И вторая метрика означает, что сколько из
того, что мы поймали, на самом деле, является событием. Поэтому, теперь две разные метрики,
мы будем с ними тоже играть смотреть, но, в любом случае, да, вот, по умолчанию стали такие
значения, но если вы понимаете, что если они из тех данных, которые мы представили,
возможно, какие-то противоречия внутри этих данных, еще какой-то истории вам не получается
достижите уровней, да, вы просто их, может, задать меньше, соответственно, в описании вашего
MVP вы даёте указания на то, почему такие значения вы указали, и мы будем с ним заработать. То есть,
это значения не какие-то там железобетонные, да, то есть, это просто некоторые плановые истории,
изначально, что они были выставлены в какие-то значения, но это не железобетонные. И будет
единозакрытый тестовый период, по которым оцениваются все решения, и, конечно, каждый
команды самостоятельно выбирает с кемовоименация. Смотрите, здесь общее требование всего LCT, то есть,
у ТЗ есть описано, как мы знаем работы, то есть, какая должна быть документация, какая должна
быть, каково должно быть, должна состоять пакет и как мы должны его распаковать, запустить и тогда,
вот. Но дополнительно, крайне рекомендую, в момент задачи, это практика прошлых лет, и вот,
я думаю, что в этом году мы с этим столкнемся, бывает такое, особенно в этом году у нас здесь,
к сожалению, отсутствуют диты, с точки зрения технологического поддержки, поэтому вполне
можем столкнуться с ситуацией, когда мы элементарно вдруг по какой-то причине не сможем что-то
развернуть где-то, и поэтому очень настоятельно рекомендую записать видео, презентацию того,
что вы сделали, видео там демонстрации, да, там какого-то, может быть даже дополнительно разместить
какой-нибудь демостент, где-то в открытом доступе, дать на него ссылочку, ну, заступом только по ссылке,
например, и так далее, то есть, дополнительно подстраховаться, то есть, даже если вы исполнили
все требования ТЗ, да, лучше сделать дополнительную историю на случай, если вдруг у кого-то из участников,
из экспертов, может быть, у всех сразу или у кого-то еще, мне будет возможность, или даже просто временного
какого-то вага, это дело по тесте самостоятельно, поэтому ваша видеопринцентация тоже может
собирать довольно существенный рост, это что касается, конечно, тестов периода, а сроки там они
устанавливаются конкурсом, у нас там более подробно, мы потом расскажем о том, как это все делается и так далее.
Следующий у нас вопрос, по популярности, это связь каналов датчиков с объектами ODS,
значит, в коллеге сообщение о том, что в предоставленных пайлов справочных каналов и объектов, да,
нет прямой связи, и как связать эти две истории между собой, есть это вид соответствии правилы
разбора, потому что без этой истории невозможно будет построить признаки по объектам участников и
участкам коллектора, здесь, наверное, коллеги, да, из Москвы коллектора. Да, уже добавлен,
обновлен справочник каналов, и в справочнике именно каналов добавлен ID объекта, поэтому это
связано было с обезличиванием и, скажем так, просто удалили не тот ID, оставили вот этот
тег технический, который с точками на IP адрес похожий, а вот самый ID-шник убрали, поэтому все
справочник именно каналов добавлен и ID объект, поэтому этот пункт закрыт. Просто надо обновить
соответственно справочных у себя. Все, отлично, соответственно, да, а это хороший вопрос,
понятные, логичные заданные теми, кто действительно смотрел во внутрянку, это очень хорошо, и все это
дело исправили. Теперь вопрос тоже по данным, опять же, о качестве, я на мане в данном. Да, они
встречаются, соответственно, как интерпретировать различные значения, отрицательные, какие-то явно
битые истории в поле значения датчика и так далее. Я так понимаю, то есть мы можем на них не
вообще не манить, может быть мы сможем как-то, если их не существенно много, может быть из-за
спопки, просто сразу. Коллеги, давайте я тоже добавлю, тогда смотрите, здесь существует опять
зависимость от производителя, дело в том, что некоторые датчики, ну или даже контроллера,
которые обрабатывают значения, здесь зависит очень сильно от их реализации, потому что, допустим,
берем температурный датчик, то есть производитель просто тупо взял и поставил значение либо -100,
либо, условно, 255, просто число интеджера, максимальное значение какое-нибудь. Мы на это,
в принципе, не смотрим, мы как на это просто игнорируем, но тут надо опять понимать, как
это трактовать, в тушке зрения, аномалий, потому что если датчик, например, сломался по определенной
причине, я его, например, просто задавил газом, там, не знаю, или просто подогрел зажигалкой,
ведь это же получается выход его из строя, сознательно, и вот такое значение, чисто технически,
технологически, скажем так, вышедшее за рамки и пределы, возможно, там же нет, допустим,
дополнительного тревожного сигнала, что, например, меня сожгли, поэтому здесь на
усмотрение, опять же, коллег, то ли исключить их, например, на период обучения и получить определенные
тенденции, либо, наоборот, включить и посмотреть другой вариант развития вот этих аномалий,
поэтому здесь, наверное, все-таки на усмотрение участников. По поводу того, что в 2021 году
было очень много, значит, тревожных сообщений, мы внедряли очередную версию вот системы мониторинга,
и поэтому в двух системах одновременно люди просто не могли работать, и вот эти тревожные
сообщения можно было трактовать, как, скажем так, систему уходила в профилактику, а человек просто
не снимал с треворью, ну, с охраной, там, с вот этой пожарной сигнализацией, и, как следствие, получал
в одной системе нормальную работу, а в другой системе вот количество этих тревог зашкаливало все
разумные пределы, миллион тревог люди написали. Поэтому здесь, может быть, 2021 год надо будет
подумать, может быть, его просто исключить опять же из анализов. Так, у меня все по этому пункту.
Да, то есть это просто именно из-за того, что данные не нагенерированы, а они живые и, собственно,
зачастую, даже если бы вы делали какую-то промышленную историю под заказ на госконтракт,
и так далее, так далее, и так далее, вы работали с таким же примером, взял данный из такого же примерно
качества, действительно, потому что, может быть, переходные периоды и так далее. Так что да, это
на ваше усмотрение, то есть понимание того, откуда вы делитесь на мали, это хорошо. Что с ними делать,
как считаете нужны, исключать или нет, в зависимости от того, как вы посчитаете правильным в вашем
конкретном случае? Следующий вопрос. В том числе, да. То есть может быть красновокупность или
хономали, да, в некоторую возможную, то есть, если вы пронанализируете, поймете какую-то тенденцию,
да, может быть более точную, то есть там, где один видит проблемы, кто-то из вас может быть увидит
какую-то наоборот, возможность пронализировать что-то и показать, что-то интересное, вполне
вероятно. Следующий вопрос у нас, насчет роли, интеграции там и все эти вот возможные истории с
авторизациями, как мы про вами доступы играем и так далее. То есть есть на готовый перечень ранее
прав, какие роли нужны кроме администраторы, диспетчера и так далее, так далее, так далее. Здесь довольно
обширенный вопрос. В коллеге могу поэтометировать со своей стороны, но я потом выгодно вам.
Да, в соседней вкладке там есть уже технический ответ, а если коворотка, то, да, используется
LDAP-согмустимая актив-директория каталог, соответственно, даже если мы там перезнесем условно
катал другую систему, это не суть важно. В целом, по ролям, насколько я помню в ТЗ все-таки это было,
то есть у нас уровень техника, это самый низкий уровень, это один объект, ну комплекс коллекторов,
один объект, мы считаем. Потом это идет уровень диспетчера района, то есть это некая совокупность
этих комплексов, совокупность всех инженерных систем, но ограниченных именно объектами. И
третий уровень это центральная диспетчерская, соответственно, диспетчер UDS, который видит вообще
все предприятия всей инженерной системы полностью, то есть все там эти 100 тысяч датчиков со всеми
тегами, со всеми порогами, со всеми тревогами и так далее. Если мы, значит, берем группы
пользователей, то созданы группы следующему, значит, по инженерным системам, то есть,
например, мы можем ограничить какой-нибудь службе, к примеру пожарку, отдельно хранку,
отдельно там, допустим, газовоздушную среду, анализ газовоздушной среды, но в рамках данного
проекта я это не вижу смысла делать, ну просто в силу, а опять же анализа самих тенденций,
тенденции нужны все, без разницы. Вот, поэтому, я думаю, достаточно будет ограничиться только
ролью группой именно по вот этим вот трём уровням, то есть техник диспетчера района и диспетчер
центральный диспетчер, диспетчер UDS, объединённый диспетчерской службе называется. Вот, по дереву
объектов, в принципе, точно так, то есть захотели, ограничили, не захотели, как говорится, увеличили
вот этот скоб, область, видимости вот этих датчиков. По инженерным системам дробить, повторюсь,
смысла нет. Спасибо. Да, ну и, соответственно, дополнительно, то есть, вопрос идет про интеграции,
различные так далее, то есть, в этом смысле не паримся, то есть, если там, там, где мы не можем,
получите какие-то данные, негих, там у нас интеграция, там, допустим, нет, с текущей отдышкой, мы
просто имитируем, то есть, просто в двух факторах делаем, паралям разбиваем, чтобы было в ТЗ, готово,
все. Ну и, все как коллеги озвучили, начинаем дальше работать. А у нас нету ролей групп реагировали,
мы не расслабливались, реагировали. А у нас дежурные бригады, они, по сути, являются также
диспетчерами, ну с ролью диспетчер. То есть, дежурный инженер, который там, допустим, словом,
буквом, там, с телефоном, с планшетом, там, на объекте ездят, у него та же роль, как у диспетчера,
который сидит 24 на 7 в офисе и там, за монитором, на видеостену, там смотрит и так далее.
Ну я бы все-таки добавил какую-то роль группы реагирования, чисто отдельно выделить ее
в группу, чтобы можно было, ну, спрогнозировать, что нужно туда, там, срочно отправить,
но это можно, да, логично, строить именно как подтверждение тех самых фактов, что ложно и не
ложно, потому что человек это делает только на объект. Все верно. Да, в общем, подтверждение может
быть на том же том уровне, на котором и создание. Окей, так, следующий вопрос у нас, журнал
UDS и решение диспетчера, где находится журнал UDS, подтвержденными, сходами инцидентами,
пожарные намрения, ложный трилога, в общем, ба-ба-ба, какой крюч связывает эту запись с
объектом и каналом датчика и в ТЗ требуется обрабатывать журнал UDS, решение у диспетчера,
но в выгрузке их нет. Будет ли журнал решений и если в нем отметки ложное срабатывание со справочником?
Да, тоже пояснили, значит, журнал UDS, у нас ведется, значит, на платформе «Джанга»,
значит, разработан свой собственный, назовем это так, в кавычках очень сильно. Хелдес,
то есть адаптированный, но он ориентирован, в первую очередь, на человек и на заявке,
который ведет именно диспетчер, то есть он может, допустим, совокупность всех сведений объединить
в одну единую заявку и, соответственно, ее отслеживать там день, два, пять дней,
сколько нужно для того, чтобы устранить ту или иную неисправность. Поэтому напрямую системы
до сих пор не интегрированы и не будут интегрированы именно из-за того, что, ну,
назовем так, море датчиков, а море вот этих вот событий связать с одним конкретным тикетом
с одной заявкой, ну, это, наверное, только нейронг способна, потому что вот выбирать, скажем так,
в системе мониторинга все-все-все события там и привязывать их, ну, это практически нереально,
это просто человек будет сидеть, заниматься вот этой вот механической работой, как это, по привязке вот
этих идентификаторов. Вот, значит, вот этому справочнику коротких, скажем так, вот этих тегов ложная
сработка, там проверка, профилактика, что там еще, выезд, ну, условно, может быть, испытания
какие-то технологические на трубах, на кабелях силовых, это все согласно справочнику, тоже ведется
в том же системе мониторинга в том же самом расширенном журнале, но мы не стали это выгружать, во-первых,
потому что люди, в принципе, здесь есть тоже человеческий фактор, то есть люди могут просто поставить
галочку, к примеру, там, профилактика, и все это устроят, так как это не является как бы
законом, ну, то есть это не транслируется ни в какие-то общие городские системы, то целесообразность
выгрузить, вот именно этот призн, ну, пока отсутствует, то есть нам важна именно сейчас аномалия в виде вот
именно анализа именно технических, технологических числовых или там винарных значений, вот,
а именно вот эта человеческая, уже составляющая, то есть профилактика или, к примеру, действительно,
там неисправность, там пожар, коллекторение, дай бог, это как раз предлагается симулировать,
симмитировать каким-нибудь генератором получайных собственных чисел, вот, ну, собственно,
наверное, это предмет как раз правильный, спасибо. Спасибо большое. В чести вопроса следующего по
популярности, наше отсутствие, отсутствующие данные, ремонта, оборудование, сварочная работа,
описание задачи фигурирует различных журналов, ремонтов, графики и так далее, и так далее,
вот, а также риэстр оборудования, люки, жертвы, камеры, насосы, вентиляторы,
эти данные не переданы, возможно, их получить будет предоставлено риэстр оборудование,
но, в общем, и так далее, и так далее, и так далее. Без этих данных, соответственно, чай там,
грубо говоря, вот, по пожарному риску даряет один из двух заявленных входов.
Коллеги, ну, смотрите, с точки зрения вот, регламентов и так далее, могу сказать следующее,
что, да, есть паспортные данные, например, на условную срок полезного использования,
есть бухгалтерский срок полезного использования, есть, соответственно,
частичные ремонты, например, в тех же самых насосах вентиляторов, то есть,
это крупные изделия, которые не меняют там целиком, а чинятся по мере, скажем так,
выхода из строя каких-то их узлов. Из-за этого у нас как раз этой истории ремонтов просто нет,
мы их не ведем. И вот это отсутствие этих данных тоже влияет на, по сути, вот, анализ как раз вот
этого прогнозирования. И если бы такая информация была, мы бы, наверное, прогнозирования внедрили
намного-намного раньше. Вот, к сожалению, здесь эта информация мы просто ей не располагаем.
С точки зрения порогов, например, если мы возьмем там, к примеру, на работку, на отказ
вентиляторов насосов, опять же, как электрооборудование, можно брать любые
усредненные значения и, собственно, от этого строить любую тенцию. Если же мы говорим именно про риестор
строительных конструкций, то есть люки, веншахты, там какие-то спеши, переходы с дверьми, то есть,
сопутствующие какие-то вот строительные сооружения, которые примыкают коллекторам,
они не являются существенной, скажем так, частью вот этого проекта. Да, мы могли бы это показать и
синтегрировать даже в расширенном журнале, насколько я помню, там есть вот эти сокращения, то
есть в текстовых метках они остались, там, например, там на пикете там 32 какой-нибудь люк,
вот, или там на пикете там 55, условно, выход из коллектора, то есть, выход это может быть и на
поверхности, это может быть еще раз спеш-переход какой-нибудь, вот, но оно не является как бы
опять же критерием, то есть, если человек там проник, ну, если мы берем вот, например, объемный датчик
или контактный датчик, то это однозначно тенденция к какому-то нарушителю. Если же мы говорим про
температуру, что, например, там есть какой-то люк или веншахта, например, люк сорвали и там
пошел холодный воздух, например, зимой и есть угроза, допустим, подмораживание, допустим,
труб, особенно холодной воды, то очевидно, что здесь без разницы есть люк или нет люк, здесь
главное именно тенденция построения температурного вот этого угрозы температурному режиму в
коллекторе, внутри коллектора, и здесь нужно опять же смотреть соседние какие-то пикеты, а куда
дальше эта температура пошла, вот, поэтому сам по себе риэстр, я думаю, здесь не так нужен, поэтому мы его
и не передали. Да, ну, соответственно, это даже да-да-да, и вот получается, это даже возможность, то есть,
вы можете просто использовать, да, действительно, усреденное значение брать из открытых основ,
какие-нибудь истории и имя оперировать, то есть это даже неплохо, учитывая тот факт,
что бывают истории, да, описанные выше, когда данных много, данные есть, но из-за того,
что там китопереходные периоды были и так далее, то есть они могут быть специфического характера, да,
а здесь было бы их еще больше, и, соответственно, это было бы еще больше путани, так что это даже
больше возможности, чем ограничение. Следующий вопрос у нас по MVP, то есть минимальный объем раздачи,
что считается достаточно минимумом? Модель в рост, пресс-дэр-борт, в общем, здесь довольно
широкий вопрос, там все ТЗ описывает, то есть там, ну, вот такая, оно описывает минимальное
требование и какие-то там дополнительные требования, они отдельно выделены. Все, что, в принципе,
написано минимально, оно, собственно, есть все самое MVP, но мы понимаем, да, что есть некоторые
ограничения, мы тоже, там, и заказчик-эспект, мы все прекрасно понимаем, что вдруг там,
из-за каких-нибудь отсутствующих данных или из-за усреденных значений, которые вы там, из-за открытых
источников будете брать и так далее, и так далее, да, где-то что-то может не срастись или там,
вообще, там не получится, это нормальная история, где-то она объяснена, почему, если вдруг там есть требования,
которые должны быть выполнены элементарно, допустим, двух факторов, а вы ее не сделали, да,
но как бы или написали почему, то как бы это уже не подпадает под MVP, это просто по формальному
признаку, можете просто отвориться от дальнейшей истории оценок конкурса, потому что не исполнены
минимум. Но в целом, да, мы, конечно, понимаем, что если что-то не исполнено, и вы об этом написали
почему конкретно, да, и особенно, если это связано с данными, с какими-то, может быть,
недо него уже противоречия, в самом-то же, какая, вроде бы, постарались этого избежать,
то это нормальная история, естественно, это можно пересмотреть и пойти дальше. Если у коньяк
нет чего добавить, можем пойти в следующий вопрос. Нет, можно дальше. Ну, кстати, по интеграции вы
уже в принципе, я все тоже сказал, есть тот же самый принцип, то есть если нужны какие-то данные,
которые не хватают, эмулировать, эмулировать или предлагать просто какой-то типовой лазовый
функционал, то есть, нет, вот следующий, он уже интеграция с внешними системами опих. То есть тот
же самый принцип, то есть создаем любые мойки, там шаблоны, типовые, как говорится, там любой Хеллдеск,
можно там, у нас вот, например, Хеллдеск используется Гелпай, это один из популярных систем для IT,
для заявок по IT-управлению. Вот, поэтому здесь, да, никто никого не ограничивает, как бы реальную
интеграцию, естественно, мы в силу безопасности, все остальное предоставить не способны, поэтому
достаточно именно шаблонов, моков и каких-то там порогов, условно, эмуляции любых опий и событий.
Да, это хорошо, да, это хорошо, потому что мы, фактически, да, даем некоторую свободу действия и
возможность самовыражаться в этом смысле. Главное, здесь не генерировать просто совсем, то есть,
эмуляция, эмуляция, да, но это не должно быть какой-то дичью, просто случайно с чистым и так далее,
то есть, там, где их можно применять, там, в части событий, окей, но в части каких-то там вот
источников данных, там, статистики, отказов, условно говоря, если вдруг у вас ее нет в доступе,
но ее мерять из открытых источников, просто посмотрите, что это, ну, более-менее похоже на
какую-то адекватность. Они просто какие-то страны с генерированной ишкой, там, данные на основе там чего-то.
Вот, так, вычистительные ресурсы, довольно только по понятым вопросам, какие ресурсы выделены на
инференс-модели, есть на граничении ресурсов на обучение, есть в индовстрии с сэйжен-дэфт-тэндом,
у иммуниатора, и есть на тестовый контур, контроллер, на время мероприятия. Ну, уже частично отвечали, да, на той истории, то есть, соответственно, вы у себя разворачиваете любом, видите там, сэйжен-дэфт-тэнд, чего хотите, делаете, на конкурсе, вы, по результатам, отдаёте пакете,
которую мы сможем потом развернуть, у вас должна быть инструкция, да, о том, как это делает, тоже это указано. Мы это разворачиваем
себя на своих стендах, да, там мы смотрим, вот. Дополнительно, как я уже сказал, есть возможности,
прям настоятельно рекомендую там, снять видео, приложить какой-нибудь возможностестовый стенд, демо, где-нибудь в открытом источнике, ещё что-то, и тогда это повысит шанс того, что, если вдруг, мы почему-то не знают,
по какой-то странной причине не смогли развернуть, и ещё что-то случилось, да, но вы хотели показать, что у вас всё сделано сфера, вот это вот, пожалуйста, ещё
демо, вот в этого и видео сняли и так далее. Это не заменяет ни в каком случае пакет, то есть, он должен быть, он должен быть выложен, весь состав документа тоже должен быть, но это дополнительная история, которая защитит вас в случае, если у нас что-то не получится, в какой-то причине, вот, а так больше никаких вот этих вот, наших,
по частничных ресурсов, ну, у нас их нет, и, к сожалению, диты в этом году у нас отварились, так что тоже не могли бы они так достать, в прошлом году частничные могли, но там довольно ограниченность, оно говоря, по ресурсам истории, и вряд ли они могли бы нам сильно помочь.
Так, следующий вопрос, по интерфейсам о повещении фильтры и адаптивности, значит, у нас достаточно для уведомления внутри веб-интерфейса, или нужны пуши, e-mail, e-mail, telegram и так далее, ну, в тестировке всё установлено, всё, что нужно, всё, что дополнительно приветствуется, вот, нужны ли эскавации, звук, повторное повещение, опять же,
то есть, если в СЗ указано там, оповещение, оно указано один раз, окей, достаточно, если вы сделаете там два-три, объясните это потом, что вот, для удобства хорошо, то есть, минимальный уровень описан в СЗ, всё, что сверху, пожалуйста, не то вас не ограничивает, но не сильно увлекайтесь, потому что не забывайте о том, что вы минимально должны сделать.
А да, нужна ли адаптивность подмобильной устройства, помните, это мы, по-моему, убирали, то есть, СЗ, специально, то есть, если вы это сделаете, будет здорово, но, по-моему, даже там убирали, если я не ошибаюсь. Нужна ли белая, тёмная тема, соответственно, такая же история, то есть, как считаете, нужна, ну, по-моему, эстетически правильно, когда есть тёмная тема, да, если у вас её нет, это не установлено на СЗ, а это не установлено на СЗ, соответственно, да.
это на оценку не повлиять, но если у вас будет темная тема, то дополнительно среди всех равных условий,
там ваша история выделится, это будет здорово, но не более того. Нужно не обновление данных автоматически,
без загрузки страницы, а именно нужными... Смотрите, здесь по поводу обновления данных должно быть
достаточно удобством пользования, вот если вы сделаете автоматическое уделие, если данные довольно
долго грузятся, да, и это влияет на скорость работы, то возможно автомат не нужен, нужна ручная,
чтобы пользователь понимал, что он сейчас запустит это обновление, и оно, условно, 5 минут
будет идти. То есть, если это не сильно влияет на его удобство, то в целом почему бы не сделать автомат?
Ну, тут смотрите сами. И как обрабатывать ситуацию, когда несколько диспетчеров видят
один инцидент, нужна реплотировка за конкретным диспетчером. Коллеги, прокомментируйте.
У нас политика, кто первый, тот и видит. Видят все, в принципе, кто отработает, ну просто будет
запись о том, что именно такой это диспетчер, там, условный Иванов, это отработал. Сидоров,
соответственно, будет просто смотреть на него в журнале, если ему захочется на это обратить
внимание. То есть диспетчера, в данном случае, в районах они уникальные, по одному сидят,
а центральный диспетчерской, там их несколько диспетчеров, они по направлению у нас разбиты.
Соответственно, они контролируют все остальные районы целиком. Поэтому, кто отработал,
то, собственно, молодец. Здесь чистая вода, одна конкретная, даже не совсем блокировка. Это
просто, кто закроет и напишет какой-то нормальный человеческий комментарий. Да, короче, не кредично,
но если вдруг, да, вы сможете добавить возможность во время открытия карточки другим, и она уже,
ну, начтение, окей, всем доступно, но на уже какие-то действия доступно только тому,
кто начинает с ней работать. Первым, окей, будет здорово. Но если вы этого не сделаете,
ничего страшного, потому что в целом, работу построены так, что, вряд ли, кто-то возьмет чужую
работу из себя. Следующий вопрос у нас по геоданам и интерактивным картам. Здесь довольно
обширно вся эта история о том, чем пользоваться, чем не пользоваться и так далее.
Ну, давайте я тогда... Давайте я тогда тоже возьму слово. Смотрите, значит, по координатам
следующая картина мира. Мы используем московскую систему координат, поэтому она, ну, не то,
чтобы закрытое, но она, скажем так, требует пересчета как раз в Яндекс-карты, там и другие,
с не важно. Соответственно, мы сейчас на эту, именно вот эту внутреннюю систему координат,
мы пока не пытаемся кого-то сориентировать, это будет за рамками проекта. Поэтому для того,
чтобы все-таки этот MVP получился, можно просто сгенерировать любые линейные объекты. Пикет у нас
это 10 метров. Соответственно, вот берем там любой объект, соответственно, у него есть там какие-то
пикеты и создаем любую абсолютно, как говорится, линию, достаточно осевой, достаточно вот этого
лайн-стринга, мультилайн-стринга и на нем нарисовать любые условные значки, какие вам заблагородствуются.
Здесь, собственно, на этом, наверное, больше добавлять нечего. С точки зрения именно потом пересчета
в наши системы координат. Это у нас сделано следующим образом. Значит, пикет это является
контейнером и внутри вот этого контейнера находятся уже сами датчики, сами объекты вот этого учета.
Если мы сейчас будем навязывать вот эту модель данной, мы реально уйдем больше в учетную
систему. То есть будем создавать некий риэстр вот этих объектов, а не тратить, скажем так,
трудочасы на именно поиск вот этих тенденций, анализа каких-то аномалий и прочего. Поэтому,
возвращаясь к визуализации, здесь никаких абсолютно ограничений нет. Просто сгенерировать
линейные объекты. Сделайте пикеты в один метр, без разницы. Все равно все вот эти движки,
о которых уже тут написали, там Deflet или Openlayers, они все позволяют как угодно масштабировать все,
что, опять же, если оно вот в GeoJSON, там, в BKT или в PostGIS, в каком-то базе данных,
оно хранится, оно все будет отмасштабировано. И единственным нюансом, почему, собственно,
я хотел бы все-таки на этом оснать, вы можете сделать именно схематичные, независящие от Geo
координат, например, схемы объектов. Ну то есть, ну я не знаю, как проще объяснить, но смысл в том,
что представьте, что коллектор, он состоит как спираль. И было бы не очень удобно видеть,
как человек бежит по нему. Если же мы говорим, допустим, что это объект просто линейный,
ну то есть человек бежит слева-направо, то есть он бежит прямо. У нее никаких поворотов нет,
то соответственно, наверное, проще было бы изобразить это в виде обычной линии и пикеты,
первой, второй, третьей там и так далее. Поэтому здесь, опять же, возвращаемся к
целесообразности. Можете условную схему нарисовать, можете попытаться реализовать.
По-моему, больше, чем подробно. Следующая санкционирована доступа. У нас здесь
как вопрос, что именно считается не санкционированным доступом и какое событие должно быть положительным
пользователем в одной или иной линии, если в данных, короче говоря, офография сохранена,
если в данном способе, полиция, есть ли в данный способ отличить реальное представление
от осложного срабатывания? Ну и так далее. Поскудамов? Да, смотрите, значит, как я уже говорил
про датчики, что можно создавать вот такие вот дублирующие системы, но вот если мы говорим
про видеонаблюдение, мы его не интегрируем с охранной системой, именно в силу специфики
распознавания изображений. То есть, пока ты сам не посмотришь глазами, все-таки, а что случилось,
реально отличить, например, дым от фара, ну, на камере ты просто не увидишь. Ну, какая-то
белая сущность. То же самое и, например, с датчиками, допустим, охранными и пожарными. То есть,
да, человек, например, проник. Если я вижу последовательность срабатывания тревожных сигналов,
что он ходит туда-обратно, там и дверь открыл, и потом другой объемник сработал, здесь можно
это именно трактовать, как действительно проникновение. Если же мы говорим про
срабатывание, прям вот железобетонно, что это ложное срабатывание, не заходя в коллектор,
ну, здесь возвращаемся к самому главному. Если у тебя, например, нет веншах, люков и просто в
середине коллектора сработал какой-то объемный датчик. Ну, очевидно, что, скорее всего, это ложное
тревога. Но никто не, опять у нас не, как это сказать-то, не гарантирует, что какой-нибудь прораб,
например, не взял и не проник, например, через поверхность, просто не раскопав, как говорится,
экскаватором условной землю. То есть благоустройство Москвы происходит постоянно, поэтому такой
инцидент мы не исключаем. И здесь вопрос просто тенденции. Если бы была статистика по таким
разрытиям, ну, наверное, мы могли бы эту статистику дать. Но это единичные случаи, когда вот в тело
коллектора или там в митрополитене, допустим, кто-то свою забил. Ну, вы слышали, что такие резонансные,
как говорится, новости, они всегда в сме обсуждаются. Поэтому, ну, здесь, по сути, будет только логический
какой-то домен, как я говорил. Ну да, то есть мы ориентируемся на какую-то популярную историю
предназируема. Какие-то уникальные истории, типа вот, да, какие-то свои еще куда-то тоже, конечно,
рассматриваем, но уже, наверное, стристепенным образом, потому что много внимания на себе уберет,
а пользы мы не получим, потому что довольно редко. Вот. По поводу камеры, кстати, отдельная тема,
то есть, да, мы просто можем в системе предоставить возможность, там, пользователя, там, отметить о том,
что он там, посмотрел камеры, посмотрел, он же смотрит вообще вандирных системах или там
еще где-то, да, ну, в данном случае у нас никаких, не предусмотрим. Поэтому, по поводу всех, типа,
опять же, камеры, да, там, и Ишек, на всю эту историю на нацеленность, не паримся, просто оставляем
на откуп оператора, чтобы он проставлял какие-то признаки, если это необходимо. Так, критерий и формат экспертизы,
значит, вопрос следующей, как фамируется итоговая танкозащита с отношением баллов за мандем,
интерфей, защиту, как именно будет проверить это качество. В общем, тогда, смотрите, здесь я поясню
по аналогии с предыдущими конкурсами ЛЦТ, с текущим конкурсом ЛЦТ, как это обычно делается и
так далее. Мы берем какое-то, какое-то решение, мы не смотрим, что за команды и так далее,
мы просто смотрим, в самом решении. Мы смотрим на формальные признаки, то есть просто пакеты есть,
лежит, да, документация есть, да, здорово, документация в полном составе, да, не в полном печально,
уже как бы минус баллс, от говоря. Пакет нормальный, его можно там распаковать, его можно там пощупать,
посмотреть, тоже развивнуть, можно, здорово. Дальше, соответственно, мы смотрим уже на
самом решении. Видит ли заказчик основной, да, то, что он хотел, то, что он прописал в ТЗ,
примерно, да, видеть, хорошо. День это вообще не то, о чем было написано в ТЗ, это тоже как бы критерии.
А также, соответственно, мы смотрим какие-то обязательные требования там, то есть, допустим,
в роли распределены, да, распределены, нет, не распределены, ну и так далее, так далее, так далее. Потом мы идем
уже по сценарии, выполняется ли тот сценарий, который мы предусматриваем, условно, он там написан,
как царевой, может быть, другой сценарий, да, то есть, это в ТЗ некий пример, да, вы можете пойти по
другому пути, вы можете, вам не нравится, допустим, прописанный сценарий в ТЗ, вы зашли в другой,
вы его показали, но вы об этом скажите, о том, что вот у нас есть другой сценарий, но можно и это
пощупать, но этот более наглядный, нормальные истории, ну и так далее, так далее, так далее. В итоге,
в общем, вот эти вот набором все функции, обязательные истории, так далее, оценка
происходит. Дальше, если, соответственно, интерфейс с человеком понятный, он не требует изучения
инструкции, инструкция есть, да, окей, но не требуется это все понятно, все логично, все здорово,
это уже дополнительный бал, если вы прикрутили дополнительные плюшки, помимо того, что у вас уже
есть некоторая база, вы, допустим, сделаем объемную версию, и это, допустим, кому-то из экспертов
покажется правильным, логичным и довольно удобным, и тоже здорово, это будет дополнительная
история, ну и так далее, так далее, сконцентрируйтесь на MVP, но если у вас есть возможность, желание и
какие-то ресурсы на то, чтобы сделать всех, обязательно делайте, это тоже, скорее всего,
будет учтенок, необязательно, вполне вероятно, что вы там, что кто-то, кто сделал MVP, но прям вот
счет, как написано, поучен больше балов, чем вы, более красивые истории сделали, но где-то там
кто-то пропустил, как-то так. У Неслава, по прошлым годам, последняя там тройка-пятерка, оценивается
очень сложно, у всех практически готовое решение, и идет уже дальше суткиная оценка,
восприятие всеми членами. 10 экспертов, то есть один чуть больше бал, поставил другой чуть
меньше бал, поставил по свою отности балов, вот некое среднее, а так по большому счету, есть
большой MVP, и еще момент, только эксперты и сумму балов, как бы больше, но меньше.
Да-да-да, то есть надо понимать, что количество экспертов такое довольно объемное, не просто
потому что людям делать ничего, а именно потому что все равно каждый по-своему смотан на разной
истории, и вот поэтому эта совокупность людей, кто-то оценивает хорошо, по-разному, вот мы и
получаем некоторую общую эту историю, и иногда разница между балом и 0.5 вполне
возможно, иногда тут одинаково оценены две команды, мы не можем поделить место, мы начинаем
там еще раз более подробно к этому подращаться, но в общем там довольно сложная история, да,
вот опять же поясню по поводу предыдущего конкурса у нас была такая история, что то
большое количество команд было, потом мы формируем некий топ-10, и вот этих топ-10 мы потом
заново еще раз проводим переоценку, обычно дается возможность там доработать эту модель,
скажем, из комментариев, которые вы получите после демонстрации своего решения, и соответственно
вы показали что там мы вам дали обратную связь, вы там допилили, сделали там какое-то
некоторое обновление, это тоже может быть отзвенено, и если вы находились у соноком на седьмом месте,
вы можете понять, что там на третье, второе, первое место в зависимости от того, такое тоже бывало и не раз.
Следующий вопрос у нас в глубинах ДТСТ и его состав, ну в частично мы уже отвечали на вопрос,
но здесь более конкретная история по поводу 12 лет, что-то за указом 12 лет, получили данные
за семь спойна нет, и так далее, вот лично моем, мне сейчас у коллеги выскажут, что и семьи спойна
лет более чем достаточно, потому что 12 лет этот был как-то очень даже неожиданно от коллег,
потому что коллеги очень отлично к этому подошли, и это прям великолепно, потому что не знаю,
из коллеги, кто-то из команды часто на предыдущем конкурсе, по другому нашему заказчику,
прекрасно помню, что там с данными было огромный проблем, в данном случае их более чем достаточно,
то что их не 12, а семь спойна, ну все равно это очень здорово, объем данных колоссальных,
коллеги может прокомментировать. Ну здесь еще есть чисто технологическая мюанс, да, ограничение,
дело в том, что когда объекты меняются, все-таки революционная база данных, она имеет жесткие
ограничения по ключам, и именно вот эти семь с половиной лет, это одна из проблем, что схема
данных настолько поменялась, что собрать, скажем так, из разных журналов, чтобы они были все-таки
атнотипным набором, атнотипным датасетом, но это просто целое тоже прям работа-работка, вот,
поэтому здесь это больше связано с технологической особенность введения любых баз данных,
которые жестко связаны в виде вот революционной модели, то есть если бы эти данные были как
обезличенные, например, как какой-нибудь Ростат видео, то тогда бы, да, глубину можно было бы
считать и 12 лет, и больше лет, то есть система мониторинга, как вы понимаете, они родились практически
вместе с компьютерной эпохой, спасибо. Следующий вопрос, у нас приоритет направлений
презентировано, тз ставит рядом прогноз отказа датчика и прогноз инцидента, это два независимых
результаты, оцениваем их отдельно или, ну и так далее, так далее, так далее, мы в принципе частично уже отвечали на все это, что ли,
можем остановиться, можем пойти дальше, мне кажется, в принципе, то есть те примеры,
которые даны там тоже за самые nsd, да, он как пример, то есть это сценарий пример, в котором мы могли бы пойти
как по усуну помыть, если у вас будет другой какой-то вариант, тоже нормально, только вы об этом напишите, как нам это проверить,
или покажите. Ну давайте, давайте раз уж голосом говорим, я еще добавлю один пример,
который не был в тз, вот например, по поводу как раз подтоплений, смотрите, так как коллектор
является линииным сооружением протяженным в пространстве, достаточно большим по, допустим,
центру Москвы, большое пересечение коллекторов между собой, а вот, и может произойти следующее,
допустим, вот у меня одна насосная станция не сработала из-за того, что просто ручью только
начался, то есть протечка находится рядом с ним, но из-за вот этого разуклона вода потекла дальше,
и вот следующий коллектор, который сединен с ним, он соответственно уже становится затоплен и насос, который
находится не в первом коллекторе, а в втором коллекторе, дает сработку и начинает качать воду усиленно,
в дренаж сбрасывает ее, но мы никак не можем понять, а что уже, откуда вода, то есть прошли коллектор,
все нормально, вода течет, не понятно, то есть вот здесь как раз и существует опять же вот
только, наверное, машинный способ, что подстроит вот какую-то вот эту модель вот этих разуклонок,
пикетов, что вот если здесь стригога сработала, а вот здесь она не сработала, то возможно,
что да, там будет сработка датчика потопления и, соответственно, включение вот этого насоса,
или насос будет триггерить, включился, выключился, включился, выключился, и вот это вот его,
так сказать, флагание, оно будет ярко светиться, как реальная аномалия, ну не может насос работать,
как это, когда самое мигало. Спасибо. Да, спасибо за очень подробные и такие яркие, значит,
примеры, потому что, в принципе, да, то есть еще раз не заморачивайся на те примеры,
которые указаны в ТЗ, если есть какие-то другие варианты, показывайте, если данные для них
более приспособлены, показывайте эти варианты. По горизонту прогноза и единицам события,
значит, за сколько часов до отказа требуется прогноз ровно 24 часа или любое значение,
не менее 24 часа, допустим, они модели с горизонтом 1, 6, 24 часа и так далее,
смотрите, вот все вот эти вот истории, да, и как вот собственно самиметрики и ешечные,
и все эти истории прогнозны, это то, что задается в системе, там, в арминке, указывается как
некая царевая история, но если данные опять же не позволяют, либо движок не позволяет,
либо это сильно замедлил какой-то процесс, все что угодно, да, делайте какие-то соваицы,
просто объясняйте где-нибудь, в полититной записке, еще где-то презентация, почему вы выбрали
вот эти значения, и все, это будет достаточно, потому что заказчик может не до конца понимать,
да там всю сложность этой задачи, и поэтому тут цифровым написал вот такой, или еще что-то могло
случиться, или сами данные с этим готовы, поэтому это царевая указанная значение по
умолчанию, но вы можете их поменять, просто обязательно опишите почему вы сделали вот так.
По чистоте предупредить тоже сам, то есть за жоплень комфортно, для условной работы,
для условного диспетчера, и опять же мы не забываем, что это демо-версия, это демонстрация,
это не готовый продукт, который мы готовы уже внедряем, это просто о том, что можно сделать,
если вот тот продукт, который вы сделаете, вдруг естественно всем зайдет, и его можно будет,
и масштабировать, и пусти в серию, и там вы уже договориться на других условиях,
и так далее, и так далее, и так далее, то есть это вот некая демонстрация ваших
возможностей и вашего видения. Дальше по формату с дачи модели и прототипа, ну как уже объясняли,
в принципе, все уже более-менее объяснено по срокам, там сориентируй коллеги со стороны
мандераторов, когда что-то ждает, вам еще раз напомнят о том, когда,
в какой момент, не пропускайте все сроки, и были такие прецеденты, когда, допустим,
мы видели, что там, допустим, все лежит, все в патетике, но мы заходим вовнутрь и видим,
что, допустим, на дитхап, там, либо на нибудь чего, занили вот этот вот документ чуть позже срока,
или там сильно позже срока, ну это влияет, это все видно, и, к сожалению, это как бы больше
минус кармин. Если у вас более-менее нормальные продукты, вы там что-то где-то забыли,
но вы прошли в топ-10, да, вы потом допилите, и все будет нормально, но вот если вы у вас все
хорошо, но вы потом загрузили позже всех, либо в самый последний момент начинаете грузить,
вдруг что-то где-то отвалилось на вашей стороне, на стороне кого угодно, интернет постоянно
глушен, да, там периодически еще что-то, вы просто по формальным признакам может не пройти,
и будет очень обидно, то есть у вас все готово, но мы не можем вас оценить наравне другими участниками,
потому что все успели, а вы нет, ну, так что за этим следите, но вам отдельно еще раз об этом напомнят,
покажут и расскажут. Мы очень неплохом этим темпею, у нас осталась эта вопроса,
соответственно, предпоследний вопрос, у нас неполный справочный канал, журнал указан на
там 12000 уникальниц и каналов, в общем, по сути, та же самая история, о чем мы уже говорили выше,
вот то, что прислали коллеги, оно в принципе останется, единственное, что то обновление,
о котором говорили коллеги, на том с однишними, вот мы его до пришлем, до того, чтобы действительно
была связка и так далее, в этом смысле все ок. И начнем 20 вопросов у нас, рекомендации под
ИО, привинтивные заявки и объяснимых прогнозов, что должно включать рекомендации, что должно
включать рекомендации по техническому обслуживанию и привинтивности, довольно обширный вопрос.
Коллеги, или могу я прокоментировать? Может заказчик. Ну давайте тогда, да, я начну,
вы, наверное, подхватите. Смотрите, здесь, наверное, все-таки, так как прогноз, это такой же все-таки
агрегированный большой показатель, который, если мы берем по инженерным системам, то есть
в пожарке, это естественно там, связка с температурной средой и какими-то тенденциями,
уфловна вплоть до того, что температура с бортом. Если мы говорим, допустим,
про температуру в зимний период, то это вот как раз аномальные понижения температуры. Если мы
говорим про инженерные системы, допустим, водоудаления, то есть насосы, то там выход
Москва-Реки, условно, из берегов, тенденции, конечно, практически такие, что у нас не
подтапливало ни разу. Но сам факт того, что такое может быть, опять это вероятностный анализ. И здесь
сезонность будет, наверное, как раз, весеннее, осеннее какие-то такие периоды. Если мы говорим про
нарушителей, ну как это, нервы у людей мы не знаем, поэтому факторы риска вообще не прогнозируемые.
То есть нарушитель может быть когда угодно. Но есть вполне характерные, опять же,
календарные точки, то есть там наши праздничные дни, то есть какие-то большие длинные праздничные
дни. Есть особые праздники, например, 9 мая. Вот на такие как раз характерные, допустим, точки можно
добавить заранее вот эти вот прогнозные, скажем так, прям конкретно аналитические прогнозные вот эти
факторы риска и описательные какие-то хрюктиристики, это все будет вот в одном, я считаю, одном длинном
таком отчете, там, например, по 9 мая, то есть сколько нарушителей было в том году, сколько в этом
планируется, там утрирую, там сколько пожаров было в коллекторе в том году, в этом году, тоже
пусть будет, допустим, 1, 2, 5, я не знаю, тут вопрос, что является опять же там пожаром, то есть,
к примеру, температура выше 100 градусов, то есть либо человек там, как говорится, сваривал там какую-то, не
знаю, там консоль и умудрился попасть на датчик температуры, ну и, соответственно, там капля попал,
металла. Здесь, вот здесь это, наверное, цель проекта, то есть вот эта карточка вот этого прогноза,
ее, по сути, и, наверное, стоит как раз разработать, а не ждать от нас, что мы какую-то вот такую прогнозную
аналитику как бы заранее проведем и дадим, потому что у нас вот эти карточки с вот этими инцидентами
недостаточно обширные, мы пишем во все сопутствующие организации, там, МОЗ-свет, МОЗ-газ, МОЗ-воды-каналы и так
далее и так далее, и в зависимости от их ответов, тоже, собирая информацию, мы все дальше и дальше
наполняем эту карточку. Вот, поэтому в принципе, эта система, если мы говорим про ее, допустим,
ну, например, если бы мы ее внедряли прямо вот на сегодняшний день, то, скорее всего, она выстала
сопутствующей к типущей системы вот журнала дефектов, журнала испытаний, журнала отключения,
ремонта оборудования. Спасибо. Спасибо большое, вот еще тут, до понятия момента, если я спрашиваю,
предлагаю перед обучением модели на накопленных данных, а до обучения приветуется, до обучения
в процессии, да, там и может быть там еще какие-то дополнительные данные. Это нормально,
совершенно. Но для MVP, да, достаточно за то, что вы просто обучили, и у вас есть возможность
до обучения, все, это достаточно, если вы еще и будете ее до обучения потом здорово, но для MVP
достаточно самая возможность. Так, в целом, мы пришли подвести вопросом, у нас, конечно,
вопросом было больше, мы выбрали те, которые наиболее популярны, у нас есть еще по таймингу
порядка там 20-ти небольшим минут, так что в целом, можно, наверное, начать отвечать на дополнительные
вопросы, которые вы сможете задать голосом. Напомню, что вы поднимаете руки и раз-добавляем
к чату. Какой-то это фрукт нет. Может, надо время подумать, поэтому мы ждем, не переживайте, у нас
есть время. Так, а в чате там что-то... В чате пишут, что ответы покрыли все мои вопросы,
благодарю, все ответы из черповыщей, мне пока что ничего больше. Да, вдруг будут возникать
вопросы, вы можете их писать в чате, я буду передавать их коллегам. Так, у нас есть одна поднятая
рука. Так, все, можно говорить. Там был вопрос про Лидеры Борт, но на него не очень ответили. То есть,
не будет возможности сравнить с собой до там определения об действия участников. Нельзя будет
сравнить метрики его соперников, никак. Смотрите, у вас будет информация о том, попали вы в топ-10 или не попали.
А после того, как вы попали в топ-10, доперим, допустим, продукт, о том, попали вы в топ-3 или не попали,
вам сообщают, что он уже на самом ребряке, когда будут объявлять там третий, второй, третий, первой,
собственно, в этом и смысл, конкурс, да, там и некая состязательность. То есть, это не олимпиада, где мы видим сразу же свои
итоги после того, как мы проплыли, например, по некому бассейну. Вот такая, как бы, да, система. Но сам факт
того, что вы попали в топ-10, не попали, да, но разумеется, в определенный срок, вы в этом узнаете. Нет, нет, в
плане, можно ли будет уклить их как бы. Я понимаю, вы имеете в виду, что у вас, то есть, допустим, вы
заперели некий прогноз, насколько ваш прогноз уходит вперед на других участках, типа там. Ну, грубо говоря,
самая главная часть продукта, она как бы, чем, как будет сравниваться. Ну, то есть тут на вопрос вам, что может ли один участник видеть результаты второго участника?
Ну да, хотя бы метр. Чтобы просто оценить нормальные результаты, даёт моя модель, допустим. То есть, мало ли у меня какая-то
целичком, какая-то колоссально низкая метра. Я делал вообще что-то совсем не так. И так, чтобы оглянуться на остальных, нет? Если можно сделать не так, то мы на встречах
это говорим. Вообще, конкурс-то было три раза, была практика такая, что очень встречи были тогда, что в десятье, в принципе,
мы представили свой проект и видели друг друга. В этом году такого не будет? Просто избава. Нет, кстати, в этом году нет, будет... Ирина, нас, по-моему,
это будет даже такая история, да, то есть во время печатейств первых у нас подключаются участники, показывают свои какие-то продукты,
там, презентации и другие участники смотрят, да, по-моему, так же у нас будет. Или как-то по-другому. Ну пока что точно нет, давайте немного подождём тут.
Ну то есть, да, такое было у нас, когда было в живую вся эта история, там, да, кто показывает, кто-то видит участие, более того, например, даже на самом конкурсе уже в финале,
когда показывали какие-то свои продукты, то есть вот эти топ-10 ещё раз при всех показывали свой продукт, проводили презентации,
все сидели в зале, потом выходили следующая команда, следующая команда, следующая команда, все эксперты сидели в самом зале, вот и потом, соответственно, выставляли в определённой оценке к совещательной комнате, да, и потом уже объявляли победители.
То есть это было, да, нормальная практика, и все присутствовали. Как будет на этом конкурсе, там, уточнился, да, ну, в принципе, но это не означает, что вы видите результаты других участников,
то есть вы, грубо говоря, видите... Вы видите их результаты, да, но не видите оценки, которые поставили в спирт, вот так скажете.
Ну да, да, в этом-то и про это спрашиваю, чтобы можно было хотя бы метрику увидеть, это обычно на всех соревнованиях и еждах присутствует, где вообще присутствует метрика, а тут она есть.
То есть там прессижен, рекол, что они себе можно...
Ну, в общем, посмотрим, как будет, точнее, у администрации.
Да, мы вернёмся тогда к этому вопросу. Станислав, у вас сейчас было плохо слышно микрофон, видимо, рукой закрывали, и у нас ещё две руки.
Ага.
Дмитрию, пожалуйста, поднимайте, включайте микрофон.
Да, здравствуйте, меня слышно?
Да.
Отлично.
У меня такой вопрос насчёт обезличения данных, может, я пропустил момент, у нас по факту не надо его сейчас сделать, уже обезличенные данные как бы.
Данные уже обезличенные, да, вы можете спокойно их использовать, как раз добавили вот то дерево объектов, которого не хватало, то есть связи между самим объектом, назовём коллектор, там, альпа, амега, и каналами данных.
Да, это если восстановили, просто выкачать надо зановосправочно.
Да, ну я имею в виду, типа, на новую поступающую данную, я считаю, что они будут такие же поступать там каждый день.
Просто, да, с новой.
И второй вопрос, маленький Excel-файл, который вы показывали, вы его нам скините, правильно?
Excel-файл какой вы имеете в виду?
Который показывали сейчас на экране, в течение всей презентации, с полответами там вот это брать.
Станислав, это к вам вопрос.
По данным всё, что мы предоставили, все обезличенные, все истории предоставили, исправленные данные, которые мы...
Не, не, не, не, у нас Excel был вот сейчас, в течение всего часа, там некоторые ответы есть.
Вы его предоставите нам тоже или...
А, это да, да, но я его...
Ну, чуть-чуть переработаете и дадите.
Да, да, да, то есть я...
Ну, из запись, да, ну и соответственно, я саму Excel тоже, да, предоставил, чтобы все было удобно, никаких секретов у нас нет, то есть мы предоставим.
Я просто туда добавил ответы, которые мы сегодня обсуждали, для того, чтобы они там оказались тоже систематизированы, чтобы все было удобно.
Я понял, спасибо.
Виктор, пожалуйста, поднимайте, включайте микрофон.
Вот же она, эксперт, здравствуйте, слышно меня?
Да.
Возможно, я пропустил ответность, но просто у меня чисто технически и достаточно узкие.
У нас есть справочный каналов данных, и в нем есть столбец D, TEC-инженерная система.
Вы не могли бы пояснить, по из себя представляет этот TEC, как он соотносится с системой, с локализацией, с альфами, амегами и так далее?
Смотрите, просто по время обезличивания мы использовали этот TEC, но потом его в принципе не стали использовать.
Дело в том, что этот ЭГИ из протоколов МКТТ, как шины данных между информационными системами, инженерными, но он здесь не нужен.
И мы добавили, заменили файл, на обычный ID-шник системы, ну, обычное число, интеджер, как говорится, целочисленное.
Поэтому вот этот вот идентификатор составной, типа как IP-адрес, как выглядит, его можно игнорировать, он избыточный.
Просто смотрите новый файл, где ID подчеркивания объекта.
Я понял, то есть канал будет каким-то образом ID канала. То есть это собственно вещь, которая показывает агин датчик, да?
Да, да.
Фактически конкретный. Можно будет прямо ассоциировать с конкретным объектом.
Да.
Ну, с инженерной системой?
Да, с инженерной системой.
Инженерная система, она в вашей интерпретации, она локализованная или пространственно локализованная, или пространственно распределенная.
Инженерная система в данном случае это один коллектор, один контейнер, один, я не знаю, там колодец, или это какая-то система, которая может распространяться на весь район.
Ну, смотрите, давайте так, значит, по текущим, вот той, значит, по тому датасету назовем так.
И по той схеме данных, которую у вас сейчас есть, мы вот эту всю пространственную, скажем так, ориентированность, мы ее исключаем.
Мы оставили только сами датчики.
Локально локализованные объекты.
Да, по конкретным инженерным системам, то есть пожарная система, соответственно, там, насос и вентиляторы этой диспетчерской управления, там охранная система, соответственно, и так далее.
То есть мы на вот дополнительную вот эту всю метафизику, там люки, вентиляторы, которые где-то находятся на поверхности, а где-то там в каких-то венткамерах, там связка, стыковка, двух коллекторов между собой, вы об этом ничего не знаете.
То есть вы можете только смодулировать вот какую-то аномалию и, опять же, мы сможем только фактически потом посмотреть свою систему и, да, убедиться, что, ну, да, такая аномалия, возможно.
Ну, то есть это не ложное прогноз, а это действительно так и бывает.
Поэтому здесь мы сузили вот эту всю учетную систему еще раз по оборудованию, мы ее сузили только до датчиков.
Хорошо, я понял.
Сузили до датчиков.
Ладно, все, тогда хорошо, спасибо.
Больше вопрос нет.
Спасибо.
Так, у нас остается 10 минут.
Давайте подумаем еще над последними вопросами и будем завершать.
Можно написать в чат либо поднять руку на ваше усмотрение.
А есть ли коллеги, которые участвовали в прошлых годах в нашей задаче?
Как Виктор, я вижу, что вы снова с поднятой рукой, пожалуйста, задавайте ваш вопрос.
Уважаемые эксперты, вопрос, возможно, уже отвечали и фактически отвечали, просто хотел еще раз уточнить.
Веб-приложение сервиса - это необходимое или дополнительное условие?
В прошлом году были обязательные условия.
В этом году из тех заданий я понял, что веб-персию, ну, мобильное приложение не веб-персию, а мобильное приложение не является в минимальных требованиях.
Я правильно понимаю?
Все так, все так, да.
То есть мы мобилку убираем.
Но создание мобильного приложения, как было сказано, будет дополнение.
Национально, все, коллеги, спасибо.
Все, пожалуйста.
Режим, господа, эксперты.
Давайте еще немного подождем.
Я надеюсь, что вопросов не осталось, встреча была весьма содержательной.
Уважаемые участники, спасибо большое за ваши вопросы и внимание, что вы подключились к нам офлайн.
Отдельно благодарю ментера и представителей постановщиков за подробное разъяснение и участие во встрече.
Вопрос, на который вдруг не хватило времени, либо у вас появился вопрос чуть позже.
Мы обязательно передадим компании постановщику.
Вы их можете написать в личной сообщении, либо в общий чат.
И все ответы опубликуем общим сообщением, чате по задачу.
И желаем командам успешной работы над решениями.
Спасибо за участие.
Сессия вопросов и ответов завершена.
Коллеги, если у вас какое-то финальное слово.
Да, конечно, мы благодарим всех участников.
Ждем на финальных встречах, дебатах. Надеюсь, все дойдут.
И получим замечательный решение.
Да, и я хотел бы сказать дополнительно, что в этом году на этой задаче у нас замечательный заказчик.
Вот со всей ответственностью и рвеньем подошел к задаче.
Это огромный шанс для всех команд, на самом деле сделать не просто что-то на конкурс.
Сделать что-то нужно и действительно то, чем люди будут пользоваться.
И почему бы не сделать что-то замечательное, поэтому участвуйте обязательно.
Это очень хорошая задача.
Так, останавливаю запись.
Всем спасибо большое.